>>> BUCKINGHAM PALACE SAYS QUEEN
ELIZABETH WILL NOT BE MAKING A
PUBLIC APPEARANCE AT THE
REMEMBRANCE DAY SERVICE AFTER
STRAINING HER BACK.
>> THE EVENT WAS EXPECTED TO BE
THE FIRST TIME THE BRITISH
MONARCH WAS SEEN IN PUBLIC AFTER
DOCTORS ADVISED HER TO REST
AFTER SHE SPENT A NIGHT IN THE
HOSPITAL LAST MONTH.
LET'S GET TO MAX FOSTER LIVE
FROM HAMPSHIRE, ENGLAND.
MAX, THE REPORT IS THAT SHE
STRAINED HER BACK.
DO WE KNOW HOW?
WHAT ELSE DO WE KNOW ABOUT WHAT
SHE'S GOING THROUGH?
>> WE'VE NOT BEEN GIVEN ANY MORE
INFORMATION THAN THAT.
IT WAS A LAST-MINUTE
ANNOUNCEMENT.
THERE'S A HUGE AMOUNT OF
ATTENTION ON THE QUEEN
APPEARING.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN HER IN PUBLIC
FOR A LONG TIME, SO EVERYONE WAS
EXCITED TO SEE HOW SHE WAS
DOING.
IT HAS RAISED A CONCERN THAT
WE'VE SPOKEN TO OUR ROYAL
SOURCES AND WE'RE BEING TOLD
THAT BACK STRAIN IS UNRELATED TO
THE REASON SHE'S BEEN CANCELING
OTHER ENGAGEMENTS RECENTLY.
THAT WAS ON MEDICAL ADVICE SHE
NEEDED TO REST.
SO THEY'RE CALMING TENSIONS TO
SAY THIS IS A DIFFERENT REASON.
SHE WAS PLANNING TO GO.
THE OTHER REASON, YOU KNOW, AS A
BRIT, IT'S SURPRISE NOTHING TO
THE SEE HER HERE, AS THIS IS ONE
OF THE EVENTS REALLY IN HER
DIARY, IT'S VERY MUCH PART OF
THE RHYTHM OF PUBLIC LIFE.
SHE ALWAYS TRIES TO GO.
SHE SERVED IN THE MILITARY IN
WORLD WAR II, OF COURSE, AND
SHE'S ONLY, YOU KNOW, MISSED
THIS EVENT SIX TIMES IN THE
PAST, TWICE BECAUSE SHE WAS
PREGNANT, AND FOUR TIMES BECAUSE
SHE WAS ABROAD.
IT'S REALLY SURPRISING NOT TO
SEE HER THERE.
THE SOURCE DID ADDRESS THIS WHEN
I SPOKE TO THEM JUST A COUPLE
HOURS AGO.
THE QUEEN'S DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED
TO MISS THE ENGAGEMENT WHICH SHE
CONSIDERS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT ENGAGEMENTS OF THE
YEAR.
JUST TO ADD, BORIS, SHE HAS,
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE HAVEN'T
SEEN HER IN PUBLIC, SHE HAS BEEN
WORKING STILL.
SHE'S BEEN DOING THESE REMOTE
ENGAGEMENTS.
ZOOM CALLS EFFECTIVELY FROM
WINDSOR CASTLE.
THEY CALL THAT LIGHT DUTIES I'M
TOLD BY THE SOURCE SHE HOPES TO
CONTINUE HER LIGHT OFFICIAL
DUTIES NEXT WEEK.
THEY'RE TRYING TO, YOU KNOW,
ADDRESS THE CONCERN, BUT NOT TO
OVERWORRY PEOPLE AT THE SAME
TIME.
>> WELL, WE HOPE THAT SHE
RECOVERS SWIFTLY AND THAT WE'LL
SEE HER OUT IN PUBLIC AGAIN
SOON.
MAX FOSTER, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT THIS
WITH CNN ROYAL COMMENTATOR AND
HISTORIAN KATE WILLIAMS.
KATE, I MEAN, WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS A SIGNIFICANT EVENT FOR THE
QUEEN, SOMETHING SHE DOES NOT
LIKE TO MISS.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT HER WELL
BEING RIGHT NOW?
>> YES.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
JUST AS MAX IS SAYING,
REMEMBRANCE SUNDAY SO
SIGNIFICANT FOR HER, BOTH AS
COMMANDER IN CHIEF OF THE ARMED
FORCES AND AS SOMEONE WHO SERVED
DURING WORLD WAR II, BEING THERE
FOR THE VETERANS IS SO
IMPORTANT.
IT'S REALLY SOMETHING THAT SHE
WOULD DO ANYTHING TO GO TO.
SO IT REALLY DOES SHOW HOW
SIGNIFICANT IT IS, HOW SHE'S NOT
MISSING LIGHTLY, SHE IS IN PAIN.
A LOT OF US WHO HAVE SUFFERED
FROM A BACK ACHE CAN SYMPATHIZE.
IT IS WORRYING THE QUEEN IS IN
SO MUCH PAIN SHE CAN'T GO TO
THIS.
SHE'S 95.
SHE'S ALWAYS IN MARVELOUS
HEALTH, THE HEALTH OF A
40-YEAR-OLD.
IT IS POIGNANT REMINDER THAT THE
QUEEN IS NEARING 100.
SHE'S NOT SO YOUNG ANYMORE.
REMEMBRANCE DAY EVENT I'VE BEEN
THERE A FEW TIMES AND IT IS A
LONG DAY OF STANDING IN THE
COLD.
IF YOU HAVE A BACK ACHE IT WOULD
BE BAD FOR YOU.
>> YOU REMIND US OF AN IMPORTANT
POINT, THE QUEEN IS 95 YEARS OLD
AND REALLY, IT'S REMARKABLE JUST
HOW SHARP HER MIND IS AND THE
FACT THAT HER BODY SEEMS TO KEEP
UP MOST OF THE TIME, EXCEPT FOR
THIS PARTICULAR DAY.
AT SOME POINT IT SEEMS SHE
REALLY NEEDS TO SLOW DOWN.
WHAT DOES THIS ALL MEAN FOR THE
FUTURE OF THE QUEEN'S REIGN,
KATE?
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
BECAUSE THE QUEEN REALLY HAS
TURNED MONARCHY INTO A VERY
ACTIVE ROLE.
SHE'S NOT LIKE THE MONARCHS
BEFORE THAT WERE RESERVED THAT
THE PALACE DIDN'T DO SO MUCH.
SHE'S BEEN AROUND THE WORLD MORE
THAN 40 TIMES, TRAVELING, DOING
OUTINGS.
HER ENGAGEMENT SCHEDULE IS
EXHAUSTING FOR ANYONE 30, 40, 50
YEARS YOUNGER LET ALONE SOMEONE
NEARLY 100.
REALLY NOW SHE DOES HAVE TO
REALLY DO MORE OF WHAT MAX WAS
SAYING, LIGHT DUTIES, ZOOM TONE
CALLS, BECAUSE THE HUGE AMOUNTS
OF TRAVEL IS REALLY QUITE A
STRAIN ON HER.
I THINK SHE'S AS SHARP AS A TACK
AND DETERMINED TO BE THERE AND
WANTS TO BE THE MONARCH, I
SUPPOSE -- UNTIL SHE'S NO LONGER
WITH US.
IT'S QUITE HARD FOR HER.
WE ALL ADMIRE THE STRENGTH SHE'S
GOT AND HER WORK ETHIC, BUT A
LOT OF US ARE SAYING YOU CAN
TAKE A STEP BACK, YOUR MAJESTY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE OUT DOING
THINGS EVERY DAY.
WE UNDERSTAND.
>> ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND.
THESE ARE LIVE PICTURES THERE
FROM LONDON AS THE CELEBRATION
IS GETTING UNDER WAY FOR
REMEMBRANCE DAY A TIME THAT THE
COUNTRY STOPS TO HONOR BRITISH
SERVICE MEMBERS.
KATE, WHEN DO YOU THINK WE MIGHT
SEE THE QUEEN IN PUBLIC AGAIN?
>> YES.
EVER SINCE SHE HAD HER HOSPITAL
STAY THREE WEEKS AGO, HER FIRST
HOSPITAL STAY IN EIGHT YEARS,
ASTONISHING REALLY HER
INCREDIBLE HEALTH, COUPLE
GLIMPSES OF HER DRIVING AROUND
WINDSOR BUT HAVEN'T SEEN PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENTS.
WHICH IS WHY WE WERE SO LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING HER TODAY.
I EXPECT TO SEE HER OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE WEEKS, MORE ZOOM
SPEECHES, BUT SHE WOULD HOPE
REALLY WITHIN TWO OR THREE WEEKS
TO BE DOING SOME KIND OF IN
PERSON ENGAGEMENT, EVEN IF IT'S
SOMETHING LESS OF A STRAIN,
SOMETHING AT BUCKINGHAM PALACE
WHICH DOESN'T INVOLVE A HUGE
AMOUNT OF STANDING UP.
FOR BACK PAIN THERE'S REALLY NOT
MUCH YOU CAN DO APART FROM REST.
YOU HAVE TO REST AND TAKE IT
EASY.
WHEN YOU'RE THE QUEEN, SOMEONE
WHO IS ONE OF THE MOST ACTIVE
PEOPLE IN THE UNITED KINGDOM,
THAT'S GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR HER.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I'M SURE DIFFICULT FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING THE QUEEN ONCE
AGAIN IN PUBLIC.
IF MY EYES ARE NOT DECEIVING ME,
THAT LOOKS TO BE PRINCE WILLIA